好,那謝謝大家
那昨天我剛剛跟CMC說起來
就昨天那個市場跌了很多
不但是昨天在跌上這幾個星期都跌了很多
我覺得先復排一下吧
就我們從12月份的時候開始說
就說降倉
然後保持至少要降至少要降到61%內
其實我在春節之後又一次叫這樣降倉
但是我自己復排一下
我覺得可能還是不夠堅決
就說當時可能要把倉戶降到更低
或者是直接叫倉倉
但是我在想就說我們做交易經常要回過頭復排嗎
就你回過頭如果復排看當時的情況
我覺得我可能還是沒有辦法給出工倉的建議
因為
這個市場其實Trump是有很大的政策不確定性
在這個政策不確定性前呢就說
如果他沒有這些問題
我們還是認為Basecase美國經濟是不會衰退的
市場還是會繼續漲
那現在市場的感覺我上次在發一個推特講到
就現在市場的感覺非常像
2008年的時候
2008年我剛好入行
那個時候就是
市場對於前面有多大的問題是不確定的
會不會發生也不確定就Supprime和那個美國現在
比方說
我當時講到三個風險
現在爆發兩個
一個是Terror
關稅
一個是Dodge
減吃字
一個是那個Immigration
這三個Immigration還沒出來
所以這三個東西其實帶來的風險
就是Trump有多認真的去執行這件事情
其實和那個當時我們看Supprime到底有多大的風險一樣
其實不知道
現在仍然是不知道
因為這是很大的我待會會分析一下
我們就是高盛年這個週末的時候
請了IM6就是那個英國那個特工部門原來的那個首席
就Head
然後做了一次那個全球
全球政治形式的一個分析
所以大家會講一下這個事情但是現在來看還是不確定
那麼不確定的情況下
講個問題吧第一個呢就說是不是繼續空倉
是不是繼續這樣低倉穩第二是不是抄底
我說一下吧就抄底來看的話呢短期
我覺得差不多是到底了
從那個內生和外生兩部分原因
但是
我是不大會抄因為我們我主要是做配置的
然後做配置的時候就好像我當時是確實看到可能會發生tel risk
但是我還是留了藏文
因為你確定不知道這個tel risk是不是會發生發生到一個什麼程度
但是這個tel risk如果在特朗普要採取更加嚴厲的政策他想把他
競選的政策全部直施的話
那麼現在肯定不是底
所以呢繼續觀望
等著看那個如果說短期的這些因素影響他的話
那麼我覺得是怎麼下怎麼上
那麼如果說這個特朗普真的把這些政策全部實施的話
那麼現在我覺得估值整個我們說估值吧就價格
超底的本質並不是說這市場跌到哪裡我在這個地方接飛刀
會不會馬上反彈
我覺得超底的本質是
在這樣的一個經濟形勢下面
是不是值得這個東西是不是夠便宜
是不是夠便宜那個p是不是夠低
從盈利盈利展望和他未來盈利展望和他現在價錢是不是夠低
如果說衰退的話我覺得美股不夠底
那個如果說經濟當然如果經濟不衰退就經濟正常的話
那美股現在非常便宜
所以是這麼一個情況
那麼我是認為現在情況是不明確的
我沒有辦法給出一個確定的情況
特朗普一個推特治國的人隨時可能改變方向的他到底怎麼樣
我會給出一些我對我對於近期的一些看法他的一些變化
但是很難很難說他最近會怎麼樣
那麼整個degross我們叫degross吧就是那個degross
意思就是市場賣出嘛整個degross在上兩周的話其實達到了
三個方差以外這個是一個standard deviation是三個方差
所以加上昨天的話我們可以認為是近兩年以來最大的一次degross
這個degross兩方面原因
我們先說宏觀基本面
宏觀基本面就是你要知道在特朗普當時當選的時候
市場的樂觀情緒是認為第一個
tariff不一定會真的來
然後FOMC就是這個美聯儲的port對於市場還是存在
因為在那個民主黨執政的時候port一直是在
那個加上doge和那個減稅會給美國帶來效率
這是一個有點異鄉情願的想法
但是這個是當時市場定價的東西所以我們看到
實驗期利率是往5%跑的
然後我們看到那個股市是拼命往上漲
當你實驗期利率在往5%跑的同時從技術上來說
美元變成了一個很好的carry trade的目標
因為雖然日元利率也在漲但美元利率漲了更多
所以整個美元曲線利率給了carry trade很大的空間繼續
重新build up了很多日元美元的carry trade
那麼在過去幾個經濟裡面其實市場得到的信息是這樣的
第一個doge真的有可能導致衰退或者導致經濟減弱
Gross下降
第二個tariff是完整的
因為本來大家覺得tariff
特朗普雖然說了他說有搞universal tariff啊什麼
我們看一下tariff的影響這個是我們上周的一張圖
那個現在也沒有變
就是大家雖然川普在競選的時候講了universal tariff
講了非常嚴厲中國60%的tariff大家大家算一算其實都是這樣的一個語氣
覺得只有中國10%其他人不太會加
這是一個理晉的語氣
但是在那個他兩次其實第一次的時候大家沒有特別當回事
也Mexico和加拿大加拿大加拿大說
這兩個任何一項的影響都比中國兩個加起來要嚴重
那麼是
加了這兩這一次加完以後他延期到3月份其實當時是想是覺得
特朗普不是完整的
但是這一次呢又搞了一下
然後雖然他是延期到了4月2號很多延期到4月2號
但是在國際上造成的這個美國和盟友特別和加拿大墨西哥的
這個關係的破裂
然後加上市場對那個特朗普這些政策會不會真的實施或者會實施到哪一步
是個問號
因為中國10%已經完成了嘛
他還在喊tariff那只會增加不會減少了
所以呢
就是tariff加上dodge這兩件事情
現在變成一個負面的東西
那麼負面的東西在結合在宏觀上來說在結合上週的話ISM啊
包括其實能防配合沒有影響太大
能防配合更多的是一個往後看
就是我們叫做backward looking或者是那個lagging index
那麼但是先行的指出
當然說ISM還有我馬的銷售
那這些東西呢都表現出美國經濟可能往下走
那麼
當你需要pricing經濟可能衰退的時候
現在美國的p就太高
S&P現在的p再降10%在18%左右
那個
再降10%
按照星期五的水平再降18%那就再降7%
再降7%p大概是18%
那麼
對比一下中國的護身300p在13%
中國現在pricing是長期通縮
這個我覺得這個定價沒有任何問題
中國就是長期通縮
但是
美國經濟如果衰退
那麼從那個pH角度來說是有下行的空間
首先
這個不光pH不光是看那個就是直接pH是多少
pH應該是看Risk premium就跟你的利率相比的
現在來說那個長端利率再往下跑
那利率再往下跑的時候你其實Risk premium也在
就是Risk premium的溢價也在相應的提高
所以你看到中國的整體的
就美國的整體的Risk premium在那個計時往下跌10%
我覺得也沒有到超級的水平
從價格上沒有超級水平
因為再跌10%利率還是會往下跑
可以如果你從價格上來做超級
那麼我覺得現在不是個時候
那個可以再等
包括我經常看的幾個標的就比方說特斯拉
特斯拉的這個整體的就是他的
他的那個下行的通道或者下行業績下行的這個區間沒有完成
特斯拉徹底把自己的左派的買家就是
他買特斯拉車都是environmental friendly
什麼這個用心能源這幫其實都左派
他包括對於特斯拉在中國的小手最近降了也很多
這個是因為中國電動車的統計嘛
但是在全球範圍裡面
他的銷量的下降和銷量下降對他業績的影響
會一直延續下去
這個一定要等到他表說有兩件事情第一個robotaxi
第二個是however5
或者第三個就是伊隆要回到公司這三件事情至少發生兩件
然後我覺得他才基本上完成他的這個下行的通道
所以在這過程中間一個很有意思的現象就是
特朗普當選了
那個國師伊隆的股票漲到488
然後跌回282
昨天應該跌282了吧
因為我之前說到了282就閉眼滿進去
但是現在我是覺得本來要跌一兩個月才到282
沒想到到那麼快
到那麼快我覺得再看看
就是你在如果說按照價值來朝底的話
我覺得現在不一定是時候
但是如果你按照超底是按照技術
或者是按照頭寸
那你保證你進去的倉穩
比方說昨天晚上進去
或者是今天再進去
你保證你的頭寸在現在是3月11號對吧
在3月18號之前能走
那我覺得現在是一個差不多到底的一個範圍裡面
為什麼這麼講
那就講到整個Train Flow就是整個交易的流水
是怎麼導致昨天的人大跌
包括最近這人跌了很多的
首先那個CDU和CSU
就是說那個德國的當權
這個是上上週德國選舉的一個情況
所以德國當選以後
德國出了一個新政
簡而言之就是大規模的消費
那德國有憲法規定這個債務上限
那他現在這一次是提出了意外
現在只是個Proposal
還沒有真正實施
但是從CDU他們的這個堅決程度上來看
這個Proposal很有可能會被通過
所以現在是pricing這個通過的
可能性就通過的這個不確定因素
pricing掉
所以他會慢慢的往這個確定性去跑
所以德國大規模的財政擴張
其實打破了這個憲法債務的限制
然後他有幾個方面
第一方面500個別鏈的公共基礎投資
然後這個大概占GDP的1%
然後第二很重要的就是對於軍事上的投資
當後我會簡單說一下MI6那個歌嗎
講到的對於全球影響力
然後全球政治上的一個趨勢
所以但是這個對於公共的投資
和特別對於房屋的投資
非常符合歐洲現在整個就是美歐之間的關係
和歐洲整個往前走的這個趨勢
那麼這個至少是2%的GDP
就是對於邦尼歐的長期邦尼歐來說
deficit widen deficit變寬1%影響
應該是40到50個basis point
所以邦尼歐理論上來說
應該往上跑80個basis point
當然那個沒有跑那麼多
這個我看看上面是那個邦尼歐的
就是那個得債利率
得債利率星期五是直接跑
那個我是星期五的
星期五是直接走了30個basis point
那麼這10年期直接走了30個basis point
市場是還需要定價
因為畢竟是個proposal
畢竟是個這個提案
市場還要去定價這個提案
到實施有多大的可能性
慢慢落實
然後才會跑出這個邦尼歐的這個變化
但是我們可以比較reasonable認為
整個得債10年期利率
應該往3%以上跑
應該如果實施的話到3%以上
因為整個GDP的刺激3%到4%
最後現在這個是2%
然後再增加其他
可能最後會在3%到4
而且這個過程是在10年的週期裡面
預算的deficit在短期裡面是5到6
所以這個過程當中
就是我們在技術上造成了得債上升
得債上升
那麼從carry trade的角度來講
日本的日本是一個carry trade
或全球流動性的釋放的很重要的幾點
這個我們之前反覆反覆
也一直講得過這個問題
大家借出日元
然後把它放在一個更加高息的環境裡面
然後做一個cross currency
把它給套利套回來
那麼原來大部分包括年初我講
carry trade都是從日元到美元
其實在美元利率這麼高的時候
為什麼美元利率美元一升息
利率一高反而股票漲
當然比它避漲
覺得不合理對吧
這其實本本質上後面
其實是有carry trade短期推動的力量
你可以把它當成一個短期的推動
就是它會讓你利率上升的時候
繼續漲一波
然後利率下降的時候先跌一波
但是長期來說
它可能沒有那麼大的影響
就是它會怎麼上怎麼下
長期來影響沒有那麼大
但是昨天來看
因為日本利率在那個得債的推動下
在星期五的時候
也基本上往上猛升為一把
升了十幾個basis point
十五個basis point
那十五個basis point
你可以把它變相認為日本央行在加息
日本央行在加息
那個carry trade昨天從美國這邊就開始
N1就開始那個平倉
那美國在那個整個市場上的
就是交易的put
其實這是個put的頭存
就是大家在買入put option
put的期權
那麼這個只是代表的整個市場
現在美國市場
從那個延伸品交易來說
我們叫做necative gamma
有很多的put
necative gamma意思
就是當股票在跌的時候
投行會繼續拋
那個它的對沖方向是股票墊還有拋
如果put越多
股票跌的越兇它就拋越多
而且它的拋的金額也會越來越大
所以這個是necative gamma
一個比較可怕的東西
我覺得其實星期一的下跌
並不完全是gamma squeeze
並不是完全美國內生的原因
主要是carry trade的交易量太大了
就是大家就從日圓裡面平倉
然後把日圓把錢從美元裡面提出來
然後因為我前面講這些宏觀因素
包括大家看到carry trade的金額
所以整個市場流動性又非常差
這個是市場的book
就是我上面掛單掛了多少單
市場整個流動性很差
你可以看掛單的當量和月初的說是差了量級
差了一個數量級
所以當掛單很少
然後carry trade在那裡強制猛賣
然後再加上投行的對沖
你會看到put option有很多
下去每一個都put on strike
然後大家繼續賣空
所以投行往下面賣的時候也是無腦的賣
所以昨天其實S&P的指數
NASA應該跌了4%
將近跌了4%
就是基本上你看到的股票
特斯拉跌了10%
快跌到220
那麼在短期裡面
你是不是到底
我覺得短期差不多到底
就是如果說超短期
這個觀點是你認為3月18號
Nedrillion英偉達的GTC出來以後你要跑
或者在這之前你就要跑
如果說長期的話
就是你是不是價格過低
這個沒法判斷
因為你現在根本就沒法
給出特朗普政策到底怎麼走
然後到底會不會衰退
這個問題回答不了
我覺得很難給出一個from
確定的答案
說現在長端是不是一個超低
我反正常就是持有性的
沒有超進去
但是短期的話
我覺得差不多到底為什麼
短期的倉位影響
能夠做空的就是
第一個degross很大
我們看到這個degross就是拋盤
拋盤很大
已經到了現在4.5個
昨天我沒有更新圖
昨天的話到了4.5個Standard deviation
到4.5個方差
那個是一個非常
我們多少99.5%的概率
所以在過去幾年裡面
基本上沒有發生過
1%他有以內
0.5%他有以內
然後第二就是市場上有CTA
就是市場上一些量化策略
CTA的策略現在全是負的
就是說那個倉位就是負的
其實已經進入做空狀態
也就是說股票再繼續大跌
你可以看右邊那個圖
股票再繼續大跌
大跌就是紅顏色的線
繼續大跌
CTA是不會賣出的
CTA只會買路
股票持平它就買路
所以你會看到這個
繼續賣出的持續的動能
其實已經不太存在
CTA上
第二呢就是我們看那個
還有一個就是那個
我們看Volcan True Strategy
基本上從高盛的Trading Desk來看
所有的Volcan True Strategy
就是策略
就Volcan True就是說
我比方說我買路股票
然後波動率達到一定程度
我就減倉減倉減倉
這個Volcan True和CTA
其實有時候是Mix
CTA也加入了Volcan True的這個因素
Volcan True Strategy基本上全部完
就全部平倉
那麼現在這一些策略呢
其實Volcan True Strategy全部平倉
就意味著如果說
有人再重新進去買Gamma
就是那個
嗯
賣Gamma
就是賣期權賣Vol
然後把那個Vol打下來的話呢
那個Volcan True只會漸倉而不會好
沒有辦法繼續跑
那麼這是第二
第三個呢就是我們看Vix
我這裡沒有寫Vix是吧
你有嗎
沒有沒有掛著Vix的圖
那這裡
Vix
Vix雖然你看它上升的比率很大
但是相比較這樣4%的幅度的股票的下墊
其實Vix沒有墊多少
沒有漲多少
這背後原因是什麼呢
就是說我們看到昨天的這一輪下墊
或者是重新就這輪下墊
更多的是全球宏觀的外部因素
而不是美國的內部因素
如果說是美國內部因素的話
就比方說一般來說
我們會看到如果市場上假設
累積了大量的賣Vol的包期權的這個投算
市場的Gamma是真的
如果發生這麼暴墊
那麼這些賣Vol的人全部要賣出來
全部要買回來
就是要這個倾倉出去
那Vix是輕鬆增升到40%以上
那麼昨天沒有發生Spike
就是Vix網上盟漲
其實雖然下跌它肯定是要漲
但是漲的幅度並沒有那麼大
我是感覺就是說從頭寸上來講
那個雖然大家現在還在Necative Gamma
Food Gamma
但是再增加這個Gamma的
Food Gamma變得更多的可能不是很大
因為在這個水平上
再繼續去買Option
買Port Option
其實已經沒有任何意義了
有人說因為買Indexport
沒有任何意義
因為Indexport已經很貴了
就快擠上以前的Single Stock了
所以很少人再會去買IndexOption
要在這個水平上再去買Option的人
必須是原來賣了
就是我SellOption
現在把它買回來
才會去買
現在買的人不多了
雖然整個Book上
我們看到很多都是Necative Gamma
機構交易和散戶是不一樣的
機構是不會在這麼貴的價錢去買Option
因為這件事情很韭菜
你幹這個事情很有可能就會
長期幹你肯定會被聽上
但是散戶不管
散戶在這個位置上就不停的買Option
買Option買了買去
但是機構不怎麼做
但是你要看
就是你們經常觀察的Gamma的Position
是用Exchange Trading
就是那個交易所交易的Option
這個是我們叫做冰山一角
整個市場交易大部分的Option交易
全部或者Option交易或者Vol交易
全部是對沖基金和投行OTC的交易
就是我跟高盛用Estar交易
不會上Exchange的
這些投存都不會上Exchange
所以你會看到真正的買Option的買價
大買價比方說原來是對沖基金
賣價也是對沖基金
他們是不會在這個水平上繼續去買
所以你看到Vixen並沒有升很多
升不上去
那麼就說我看美國內生的這些
內生的這個因素和外部因素
外部因素的這個paratron Y
我覺得可能沒結束
明天還要繼續搞
那麼但是內部的因素
其實已經沒有繼續的賣壓了
所以你說如果在短期裡面要去超低
那麼你看的是GTC
包括英偉達的GTC
你會看就說不去判斷
特朗普會不會導致這個衰退
那麼我覺得投存上來說是可以的
但是我不會去做
那個我是更多的看
覺得這個價錢達到便宜
就是說不衰退
現在價錢肯定是便宜
衰退的話
你對繞一下中國13%
13%是13
那說一下中國的情況
就是說東升
上次我講過東升西江的問題
東升西江肯定是絕對沒有可能是這個選項
中國通縮的問題其實也沒有完全解決
中國的經濟出來一個新的數據
就是CPI右降
CPI右降代表它通縮問題並沒有解決
我一直是覺得中國通縮
這個數據可能還是會有一些水分
有水分的數據尚且如此
就是說中國真正就是說這麼一個簡單的邏輯
中國是一個供給提供房
美國是一個需求提供房
經濟增長靠的是需求不是供給
供給你能夠掐脖子
能夠提供多少供給
並不代表的你國家經濟會怎麼樣
中國被掐脖子的原因
是美國把中國當成人框
當成一個生產基地
但是你要把盈利收回美國
美國才能夠繼續消費
所以這些高科技都是把盈利收回美國的
在這過程中
中國如果是希望去提供供應
要得到這些掐脖子的技術
那麼美國可以選擇不跟中國做供應
那不要你供應
不要你供應
你能做什麼東西你都垮掉
因為中國本身是沒需求的
沒需求問題一個是人口
第二個資產負債表
然後嚴重的通縮
所以它是很難有需求的
那麼現在特朗普改革的本質是什麼
本質是他要把政府端的需求給砸下來
他要減少美國的需求
要提升美國的供應
這件事情在經濟上是不可能實現的
你想這個最基本的Economy101
對吧那個經濟的需求在減少情況下
怎麼會增加供應呢
他要把那個Manufacturing回到美國
那麼他說採取的政策就是關稅
那麼他這個關稅就要對應於
不光是中國對應全世界
因為中國有很多轉口貿易
所以要對應於全世界
要把中國的這個供應掐在外面
然後提升自己的供應
首先我覺得
這都是天方夜談是不可能成功的
那麼也就是說
當你需求在減少時候
供應是很難提高
這供給測的改革
至少要回到美國都不可能
但是他採取這三方面政策的結果
是受傷最大嘗試的結果
受傷最大一定是供應提供方
因為他不提供需求了
或他減少需求的提供
所以你說中國會不會東升西降經營
沒有任何可能
中國只有可能西升東不升
或者是東平穩
這有可能
或者是西降東必降
這個大概率的情況
所以中國的簡單說
它的經濟情況
就是說外貿還是占美國占14%
這個是統計口降
其實很多都是轉口貿易
中國最終的消費還是在美國
第二個我們看到一個
這個數字我沒有放上去
但是第二個比較重要的是8.7的下降
進口下降8.7%
結合CPI
這個不是季節性調整
這個就說明
你的整個通縮的情況並沒有解決
中國政府採取的政策
都是讓私營部門繼續加鋼桿
繼續去消費
然後繼續去加鋼桿繼續去投入
但是私營部門資產負債表
已經縮水到現在這個水平
以加任何鋼桿不會成果
所以我覺得現在市場
還有一點很像2008年的時候
2008年的時候
大家就我講講到
大家對前方不確定
Suprise在美國不確定
所以很多的資金到了
Emerge Market
那個時候有Breaks國家
然後到了什麼南非中國印度
什麼這些Breaks國家
包括BNN
那個越南
但是一旦美國真正開始跌了
美國真正開始跌了之後
這些國家也是供應提供房
不管你是原料提供為中國
中國提供這個產品給美國
還是你是本身就依靠著美國消費的
當美國經濟真正衰退的時候
09年真正衰退的時候
這些地方是跌得連渣都不深
所以美國是能夠返回去的
這些地方是返不回去的
所以我覺得現在有變成08年
這種狀態的可能性
就是這個時候風險
但是對於特朗普政策判斷了
我其實本質上沒有那麼悲觀
就我覺得經濟衰退
仍然我去經濟衰退是小150%的
這個概率還是小150%的
這個是我個人對特朗普政策的一個判斷
但是不一定對
你就是這個自己看
現在市場的定價的
我覺得現在市場定價衰退的因素
有點偏大
就這個是那個叫Alex Younger
這個人是原來MI6的頭
那前兩天在高盛的
就周末的時候
就做了一個分享
就是說現在美國政策是什麼
就本質上它是一個更加長期的政策
換上民主黨
它也不會有本質的變化
它只是一個趨勢更快或趨勢更慢
本質上是美國經濟起亮
它沒有辦法經濟的能力
現在沒有辦法達爾堅基天下
它人口的問題
或者是經濟佔比的問題
達爾堅基天下
就是它管上歐洲管上日本
管上全世界所有地方
它要所有地方全部給它管上
過去的這個經濟的模式
是它達爾堅基天下
然後把天下的營利
全部歸到美國消費在美國
但是它現在沒有這個能力
根據特朗普 GOP的這個政策
其實也是美國國內民意也有這個影響
就是它要減少部分的全球影響力
然後比方說在歐洲
讓歐洲發揮更大的作用
它要把自己的就是
美國的國家核心戰略
它要把自己的所有的focus
對著一個國家就中國
所以它真正的conflict
真正的矛盾
或者認為它的競爭對手是中國人
它不應該在俄國身上花費太多精力
那麼在歐洲它一定是一個減少
或者是retrieved往會撤的
在烏克蘭的問題上
包括你看特朗普的表態
特朗普的政策
前兩天其實它有一些回頭
但是這個大趨勢是要全部後撤
所以這個後撤的過程中
烏克蘭即使達成了和平協議
或者是達成某種程度的停火
最後歐洲就會一直留著
烏克蘭的open ended question
就是一個開放式的命題
這個開放式命題
不光是對著烏克蘭
同時對著波羅的海三國
這個三國家雖然在北約裡面
但是很難想像
美國真的會為這個三國家駐兵
那麼打了一仗以後
俄羅斯的力量其實虛弱了很多
它打了很很很差
所以它要真的再去擴張
3到5年以後的事情
所以在這個過程中間
其實歐洲的我們認為就是
這個是Alex Younger他的認為
是整個歐洲在build up
他的minitory
重建他的軍事體系
因為歐洲的從文化上
從整個意識形態上
從整個社會的狀態上
他已經把房屋這件事情拋棄了
他進入一個welfare state
變成一個福利性的社會
他希望真的跟加拿大一樣
一個福利性的社會
房屋就靠美國
但是這個本質的概念
現在在德國帶頭
把這個事情給改變了
所以最後怎麼變化
還是要也拭目以待
但是全球的房屋開支是必然強生的
所以這個是一個毫無疑問的事情
所以我覺得就是說
今年的一個投資的一個
壯的一個可能好很好的標的
你可以去看這個房屋的
就是trend
趨勢上來看是房屋的
那麼這個是歐洲的一個整的狀態
所以但是
這個是特朗普的政策
所以他對中國的關稅
和各方面影響會繼續增加
那麼但是為什麼我說
特別在短期裡面
我沒有看到美國一定會衰退
或者我對美國衰退這件事情
沒有那麼悲觀
我確實相對來說
比市場原來比市場定價的要悲觀很多
我在12月份讓大家去減倉
減倉
減半倉
但是我現在比市場定價
稍微樂觀一點
因為我看最近有兩件事情的變化
第一件事情
他把伊隆馬斯克
從Doge的這個department裡面
變成主導
變成顧問了
也就是說這個其實本質上
可能是伊隆馬斯克
和那個馬克儒比爾之間的一個爭論
但是他其實我覺得
他王普能夠忍受
大家在烏克蘭上把烏克蘭放棄了
能夠忍受
跟加拿大和墨西哥沒有搞白
搞關稅
能夠忍受去針對中國
把中國關稅全部加上去
然後能夠忍受
immigration導致的一些
那個inflation導致的一些通縮的問題
他也能夠忍受股票下跌
他能掛在拜登頭上
他其實市場就pricing
他希望股票下跌跌了更多
掛在拜登頭上
但是他不能忍受
這些東西的一個積微久的
組合全國了
那就要掛在他的頭上
所以他光是在烏克蘭問題上
在上週的時候
其實有一個放軟
他雖然聯繫了烏克蘭的反對派
反對派不跟他合作
然後他要在沙特去跟烏克蘭談判
然後第二個就是
包括他對於鬥志政策在緩和
他雖然講到
我需要把美國基本面變得更好
所以我不是那麼在乎股票
但其實股市的這個下跌
必領出動他
對於他很
我認為在政治上
他很難能夠就是這三方面
這幾方面的影響同時接受
那麼在那個短期裡面
他的政策
我覺得變緩的概率會變更大一些
但這個完全是我個人害怕
這個不一定是對的
對於市場
就是說你要長期的持有
你一定要等到這個信號
更加明確以後
因為現在市場pricing
他就是衰退
他就是川普就是想衰退
而且pricing原來
Fed put在嗎
不在了
Fed put本來有兩個put
財政put和Fed put
經濟一不好財政就要支出
經濟一不好
Fed美聯儲的put就會在
現在Fed put再不再不知道
市場定價經濟一不好
那個政府的put不在
所以我能夠原來的想法
他說我能夠忍受經濟
就total demand
總需求下降
那麼讓經濟就是
進入一次人為的recession
那我現在覺得他這個
就是從政策上來講
他希望更加平緩
就是經濟放緩
不是變成一次衰退
所以這個定價是不一樣
那麼我們繼續觀察
我是對於整個基本面
Base case
就我們Base case
就超過50%可能的這個情況
我是相對更加樂觀一點
但是呢
當你因為你不是空藏
像我們來說
其實手上是有倉位的
那之前其實我們副牌來說的話
我再說一下
就說我在想
我回到當時
我會不會緊藏
我可能也不會緊藏
因為確實
你沒有辦法判斷這件事情
所以我們頭上是有倉位的話
那我覺得是現在是不適合
買槓進去草地的
我給你是很短時間要跑
好吧
那個我大概把這個情況
跟半個小時
跟大家簡單聊一下
看一下你們有些什麼